vous avez vu andré billardon remettre
l'écharpé et david marty hier une
question se retirer en cours de mandat
on a vu michel bachelard et quetigny
aussi il ya jean esmonin qu'il la flèche
nos en côte d'or et c'est une façon
court circuiter un peu les électeurs
finalement parce que finalement il ya
toujours un sortant quoi votre dany
martin sera sortant pour - debrecen
municipal donc on remettra pas des
choses en jeu quoi dans la question que
vous pose est celle de la légitimité du
maire qui devient maire en cours de
mandat évidemment ma conception de la
fonction de maire c'est qu'il est le
chef animateur le leader d'une équipe
mais que toute l'équipe est investi par
le suffrage universel
en d'autres termes toute l'équipe
municipale que j'ai peut-être un peu
conduite à la victoire
il ya deux ans est tout à fait légitime
et donc moi je considère que le
l'animateur est légitime
l'animateur a toute raison d'être le
maire de tous et donc c'est une pratique
surtout dans des périodes compliquées
qui je crois à son mérite à savoir de
faire les choses en douceur parce que
les défis qui sont ceux d'une ville sont
suffisamment importants pour qu'on ne se
perdent pas dans des querelles inutiles
vous parlez de période compliquée on y
vient justement le creusot c'est une
ville particulière aussi parce qu'autour
de cette usine il a fallu de la
manoeuvre
la main d'oeuvre il ya beaucoup de
communautés étrangères qui sont venus là
on parle souvent la communauté polonaise
au creusot qui est très ancienne il ya
bien sûr d'autres communautés étrangères
qui sont venus s'installer au creusot on
parle beaucoup en ce moment le maître
mot c'est le vivre ensemble et il est
parfois difficile à maintenir dans une
ville entre gens d'origines différentes
de classes sociales différentes
quelle est votre position à vous de
maire du creusot pendant plus de 20 ans
là dessus et ce qu'il faut tenir compte
des communautés étrangères
et s'il faut faire des efforts pour elle
est-ce qu'il faut trouver une autre
façon de faire
d'abord je crois beaucoup à
l'intégration et au creusot
l'intégration s'est faite naturellement
par le travail les premiers migrants en
nombre important ce sont les polonais et
puis les italiens les portugais les
espagnols
maghrébins dernière communauté installée
au creusot les turcs et chacune d'entre
elles a souhaité souvent conserver son
identité
pour revenir aux polonais premiers
arrivés les polonais encore une identité
au creusot mais qui peut dire qui ne
sont pas intégrés au creusot personne
évidemment
par conséquent c'est un long cheminement
qui doit prendre en compte à la fois les
identités mais qui doit tendre à un
objectif à un but à savoir que la
société creusotine a cette chance et
richesses d'être composée de tous ces
apports successifs mais c'est vrai les
périodes sont parfois difficiles pour
arriver à cela
alors le maire et de faire quoi il doit
donner aux communautés ce qu'elles
veulent où il doit essayer de les
unifier
j'allais dire ils doivent faire les deux
et il doit permettre à chacune d'entre
elles de s'exprimer alors est là elles
ont par exemple quand elles le
souhaitent
au creusot leurs propres locaux il y a
une vie associative polonaise ou aux
italiennes ou voire pour d'autres
et puis en même temps il faut trouver
des moments de rassemblement à
l'occasion de certaines manifestations
il faut que les communautés se
retrouvent les unes avec les autres pour
à partir de la diversité faire un tout
c'est à dire quelque chose qui est
identifiable comme étant la société
creusotine
c'est encore une fois souhaitable c'est
un long cheminement surtout il faut
accepter la durée dans ces affaires là
et me semble-t-il il faut que l'équipe
municipale et et singulièrement le maire
soit celui qui donne le la dans ses
affaires parce que il faut faire très
attention aux dérives
surtout dans une période comme celle que
nous vivons aujourd'hui vous avez dit
tout à l'heure c'est le travail qui
intègre et ce qu'a contrario c'est parce
qu'il n'ya pas assez de travail en
france aujourd'hui qu'on a cette
difficulté de votre point de vue
évidemment
évidemment ça y contribue ça n'explique
pas tout ça n'explique pas tout parce
que quand je dis les dérives je pense
naturellement au vote pour un parti
extrémiste pour un parti populiste
donc rien ne justifie de mon point de
vue est que ce vote se développe pour
autant il est là et il sent il s'est
enrichi évidemment des des cris de
colère de ceux qui ceux ci me sacrifier
de notre société et on peut les
comprendre il faut être attentif à leurs
discours
mais ça ne suffit pas à expliquer le
succès de ce parti vous avez bien pu
constater à l'occasion des dernières
élections régionales en particulier que
dans certains bourgs
vous aviez un vote front national qui
approchait les 40 voire davantage
alors même que le chômage n'était pas
présent dans ce bout ou peu présent par
conséquent à la pause un plat 25% au
creusot c'est 26% 26% et ce qui me fera
beaucoup c'est aujourd'hui au à
l'occasion des élections régionales au
deuxième tour c est autant un point près
c'est autant que la droite républicaine
le parti socialiste se rapproche des 50
nature alors pour autant vous vous avez
fait le choix par exemple de soutenir
deux projets de déplacement et
construction de mosquées au creusot
alors que le débat ça vous est reproché
par parler le front national en
particulier de votre point de vue il
faut soutenir accompagner cette manière
là et pas refuser tout ce qui peut
relever d'une communauté sur sur la
question sur la question des lieux de
culte et en particulier des des mosquées
moi je considère que chaque religion a
le droit à avoir sa place et en
particulier son vieux digne de ce nom
dans une société surtout lorsqu'il
s'agit d'une société comme la société
creusotine et par conséquent la ville je
le place en termes de devoir la ville se
devait de créer les conditions pour que
des lieux de culte qui était devenu
inadapté pour les populations qui le
fréquentaient ces lieux de culte ce
puits se déplacer dans des lieux plus
convenable par rapport à l'exercice du
culte
ce qui est vrai pour une religion doit
être vrai pour n'importe quelle religion
est celui qui vous parle qui est de ce
point de vue extrêmement distant par
rapport à là où ce phénomène religieux
avec tout cela comme étant un véritable
devoir de premier magistrat
est ce que la culture fait partie de
ceux qui dans une ville peut contribuer
à souder l'ensemble de la population
vous voyez venir ma question au creusot
20000 habitants à une scène nationale
est-ce que c'est pas un petit peu petit
pour une scène nationale après la
culture c'est une question de priorité
moi je pense que l'intégration se fait
aussi au niveau de l'intelligence
plus les gens seront intelligents et
plus l'intégration se fera
puisqu'on vient d'évoquer la question
des migrations est donc là le lange lieu
culturel est un enjeu majeur
je suis très en colère quand je vois on
le constate presque tous les jours que
certaines villes ont compris la culture
comme étant la variable d'ajustement
les difficultés financières des communes
une chose pareille non la culture doit
être à mes yeux une priorité parce que
c'est la priorité à l'intelligence de
tous et par conséquent scène nationale
festival médiathèque
toutes les écoles de danse ou
conservatoire de musique
tout cela est une absolue nécessité pour
une ville comme le creusot et je leur ai
défendu jusqu'au bout et je suis
convaincu que mon successeur empruntera
la même voie on parle beaucoup dans les
communes on a entendu les maires en
parler la radicalisation de certains
jeunes de la communauté musulmane est ce
que le maire que vous avez été jusqu'à
il ya quelques jours il se préoccupe de
ça il est au courant ils s'inquiètent de
ce type de chose qu'est ce que vous avez
à dire la vigilance oui il faudrait vous
l'avez observé au creusot vous le savez
il y à il y à une nécessité d'être
attentif à l'évolution de quelques-uns
naturellement alors il ya un endroit où
nous la question c'est est approfondie
et travailler c'est ce qu'on appelle le
cispd alors sur le conseil intercommunal
pour la sécurité et la prévention de la
délinquance qui regroupe les communes de
l'agglo
ration du creusot où on réfléchit tous
ensemble ensemble ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire l'éducation nationale ça veut
dire les collectivités locales
cela veut dire les forces de police et
de gendarmerie ça veut dire les
bailleurs sociaux
ça veut dire les tous les acteurs de la
vie sociale y compris les associations y
compris le département dans dans dance
irresponsabilité se retrouvent pour être
attentif à tout cela et depuis
maintenant deux ans je crois nous avons
mis parmi nos priorités la question de
la radicalisation avec de la formation
direction de celles et ceux qui ont en
charge en particulier les jeunes vous
savez que développe depuis un certain
nombre d'années maintenant le les
activités périscolaires et bien nos
encadrants des activités périscolaires
sont tous désormais formés sur cette
question de l'enjeu de la radicalisation
parce que il faut être extrêmement
attentif le creusot a été touchées très
directement lors des attentats de paris
au bataclan particulier et dans le
quartier c'est un dévot dernier moment
mr d'ailleurs finalement en action c'est
vous l'avez vécu comment c'est un moment
particulièrement difficile vous savez
que les deux jeunes femmes de jeunes
femmes d'origine des creusotines c'était
en même temps des jeunes femmes de de
l'immigration maghrébine viendrait
symbole à votre wii sans vouloir et est
du coup l'émotion au creusot a été
considérable et les creusotins jeu
mise à part une toute petite minorité
ont serré les coudes et ont compris
qu'il y avait derrière tout ça des
enjeux qui étaient des enjeux majeurs et
quand je vois ce que nous faisons pour
l'accueil des réfugiés en particulier
des réfugiés d'origine syrienne
aujourd'hui au creusot nous avons
répondu tout de suite on vient on va
dire même si des communes qui seront
proposés tout de suite absolument quand
je vois les lans qui s'est créée au
niveau associatif pour accueillir ces
personnes je pense que ce contexte du
moment a été quelque chose de décisif
il nous reste une minute trente andré
billardon armor à regrets aux journées
plein alors si si si je vous dis si je
vous dis tous mes romans il faut plus
d'une minute une minute et demie il en
est un qui et obsédant pour un élu c'est
de ne pas avoir réussi à entraîner tout
le monde tout le monde je dis bien avec
lui et par conséquent considérer
aujourd'hui que certains s'en vont sur
des voies qui sont des voies totalement
à l'opposé de ce qui a été la mienne me
donne un sentiment d'insatisfaction et
et de ne pas avoir tout réussi
naturellement et puis sans doute aussi
quelques dossiers mais j'ai au moins
fait une chose croire je tiens à
l'évoquer c'est je ne crois pas avoir
laissé passer une opportunité car j'ai
pris me semble-t-il les risques quand il
fallait les prendre c'est dur de passer
la main à vrai dire d'arrêter
oui c'est difficile oui c'est difficile
parce qu'en plus moi je n'ai fait que ça
depuis presque quarante ans même un peu
plus si je prends la totalité de mes
mandats c'est difficile mais que
voulez-vous les années sont là les
dossiers ont été l'essentiel ont été
menées à bien
c'est une satisfaction et puis les
résultats électoraux de l'année 2015
m'ont conduit à considérer que c'était
le bon moment
merci beaucoup qu'andré billardon d'être
venu prendre du temps pour évoquer avec
nous votre votre carrière
samedi prochain rendez-vous même heure
même endroit pour un nouveau numéro de
la voie est libre avec un débat sur le
projet de déchéance de nationalité bon
week end au revoir et merci